[Music]
Democratic convention starts tonight I
can feel the energy in the room Wow okay
no this is big this week the Democratic
convention takes place in Charlotte and
North Carolina and one of the speakers
will be Bill Clinton yeah yeah out of
habit Clinton told Hillary that he was
nowhere near Charlotte he doesn't know
who Charlotte is and and Charlotte is a
liar that was his last she's I don't
know and she's a liar
this is a tonight's event at the
Democratic convention included a speech
by Michelle Obama she gave a speech yeah
yeah everyone's favorite moment was when
the first lady told Ann Romney to bring
it [ __ ] that's what she said
that's a quote I saw and I'm reporting
it donors if you're a donor to President
Obama's campaign donors to President
Obama's campaign were promised exclusive
access to Joe Biden and for an extra
$10,000 absolutely no access to Joe
Biden really you up here you got Chuck
Norris said Andy I did hear what he said
that's right we rehearse this together
Chuck Norris said that if President
Obama is re-elected it will lead to
quote a thousand years of darkness then
he said if Romney wins it will lead to
four years of extreme whiteness Jordan
Nick a crazy Nicki Minaj has come out
with a pro Romney song that contains the
lyrics
you lazy [ __ ] is effing up the
economy
yeah after hearing about it Mitt Romney
said I don't know who Nicki Minaj is but
he sounds like a great guy
now the Republicans are really going
after Obama they're attacking him very
hard this week the Republicans have been
asking in the last couple of days are
you better off now than you were four
years ago in response Americans are
saying no were worse off because four
years ago we had never heard of honey
boo boo I yearn for that innocent time
[Laughter]
DC Comics we are new comic fans here
[Applause]
[Music]
that's so unfair our voices will be
heard
DC Comics has unveiled its first
arab-americans superhero yeah he's the
first superhero who has the power to fly
but keeps getting pulled aside by
questioning for the TSA
[Applause]
the next I wanted to do it for just a
little too long yeah and I did this is
where if you heard about this rumors
have surfaced that Bruce Willis may sue
Apple so he can pass on his iTunes
collection to his daughters must have
passed it on so is sue Apple yeah this
could be an important case because if
there's one thing all teenage girls love
it's their dad's music collection got to
mention this in Massachusetts my home
state a prison inmate serving a life
sentence will be allowed to have a sex
change operation wow this is great news
for him and even better news for his
cellmate
[Applause]